yeah what's up how you I'm good man you
been all
right I'm you you after our conversation
I seem like uh you know you're a very
respectful man but you kind of lose you
lost your temper brother man you know
I'm human man sometimes we lose our
temper when we deal with certain amounts
of stupidity we all do with it we all do
with
it well you know I wanted to argue about
something earlier uh you said
last debate that the Quran
says that the the Torah the Bible and
the was all valid sources yes but it
doesn't it doesn't really say that it
says the in the Torah and they said they
don't say they're valid sources but they
say look into them when you're in doubt
not really uh that they're
valid look into them when you're in
doubt
why well you see now uh I understand
what this means because you know some of
the stuff in the stories like in the
stories of the prophets like Prophet she
and G like the two stories of the kids
of AD Adam and Eve some of the
information was missing like not it
wasn't all revealed in the Quran so you
can look back and it's not saying
anything blasim like Jesus Is God so we
can look at that and say that's valid
information so it would mean that the
previous books are valid for him to
check the stories of the prophets well
not all all of them because you know it
wasn't until like I think 200 years
after the Bible the Trinity came out
well that's not true but just even even
even even without that just you said
that if you're in doubt go to the
previous scriptures to be able to verify
the stories of the prophets and the the
and the people that he was getting
revelation of so that would mean that
the scriptures were valid to go check so
that they can verify his own Revelations
right no brother because you you're
interpreting it in a different way you
know if it's if some of the uh some of
the stuff is missing because in the
Quran it states clearly that Jesus is
not God and the people that started
saying that he uh is uh not not doesn't
say that actually it says there's no God
but Allah and there's only one God and
it doesn't stay like that well this is
that's the problem bro that's the
problem that I have I want to I want to
address what you said okay saying so
that's not missing but I I me as if
something was missing because some of
the stories like with G and his
sister the four the two brothers and two
sisters I I want you I want you to I
want you to think about what you're
saying you're saying that the scriptures
are not valid yet they're good enough
for you to go back to check them so that
you can verify what the Quran is saying
in certain places okay then could you
pull up the how does that make sense
could you pull up the actual verse in
the Quran yeah chapter 10: 94 if you are
in doubt about what we have revealed to
you then go and ask the people who've
been reading the scripture before you be
not of those who doubt wait wait go ask
the people that who were reading the
scripture before you yes so it doesn't
even say that uh go read your scripture
exactly where where would they be
getting their information from
what are you talking about because I'll
tell you I'll tell you a story no no
don't don't tell me a story just please
let's stick to let's focus on the
argument here where would the people be
getting their information like he says
if you're doubting what we revealed to
you then go ask those people who've been
reading the scripture before you so when
he goes and asks them about what Allah
revealed to him and they verify like
yeah or no where would they be getting
their information from to verify what
Muhammad is
saying okay I'm about to tell you I'm
about to tell you who they asked that
was reading the previous scriptures
because this there's a source of this
somewhere that's not that's not what I'm
asking name he was his book was the
Torah and I'm gonna tell you where he
was from so so there so he'll be getting
his information from the Torah right yep
and you know he said he said that
Prophet Muhammad was going to be a
prophet keep him away from the hatred of
je no worries I I don't I don't care
about that I only care about the
argument that the verse is bringing
yeah so so pay attention please pay
attention to what's being said here
please pay
attention so you have the
Quran saying that you can go to the
previous to the people who have been
reading the scripture before you
Muhammad if you're doubting about what
we revealed to you so their scripture is
good enough to verify the Quran right
you trying to twist my words and
interpret what I'm saying as the for you
how you guys interpreted the I'm not I'm
not even saying what you're saying I'm
saying what the verse is say how about
you take what I'm saying exactly how
about I say it to you you you're saying
so you're saying the scriptures are good
enough never said so you're saying I
never said so you're saying I'm talking
about the Quran you actually did say
that you should start streaming so you
could go back and if you said that
brother
next hello what's going what going on
how you
doing good how are you I'm Excellent Man
blessed by the Lord
Jesus amazing um okay so just to get to
the topic straight away
um um Pro Jesus is a Muslim so I can win
this uh
$2,200 maybe you can convert it in
pounds if I
win yeah so yeah uh just to get right
into it um so was Jesus a
human
yes amazing was he a prophet
yes did he submit to the one true the
will of the one true God
yes was he Bound by the
laws
yes uh do you know what a Muslim is yes
so when do I get my money once you prove
that Jesus is a
Muslim I just proved it you just said
he's a human MH yeah he's a prophet MH
and he's Bound by the laws and he
submitted his will to the one true God
let's not forget let's not that he he
was circumcised he followed the dietary
laws
he can you show me where can you show me
where the Quran commands you to get
circumcised
we're not talking about the Quran we're
talking about proving Jesus you
yeah wait you're talking about being a
Muslim you're talking about the Quran I
just won I just won when do I get my
money once you prove that he's a Muslim
you're indebted you're you know once you
once you prove that he's a Muslim once
you prove that he's a Muslim I'm still
waiting on that already God knows God
knows God knows you're student of I'm
just I'm just I'm just waiting I'm
waiting on you to prove it you're a
student of Sam shamon can can you show
me where the Quran to get your
circumcised W this or you you're just
about to run off now you sound like
you're about to run off if I don't get
it in this life you're you're about to
run off remember bye then
bye I've won bye I'm not running nowhere
oh you're not going oh okay you can stay
you can stay as long as you want all
right don't go but I'm just I'm trying
let you know I so so let's talk about it
then are you ready to talk about it uh
no there's nothing more to discuss you
said yes yes yes you haven't told me
what a Muslim
is a Muslim is somebody who submits to
the one true uh to the will of the one
true God and who follows follows the
laws that he has commanded is the one
true God of Trinity he's a human I got
you let's talk let's let's talk let's
talk is the one true God of
Trinity now we're going to change the
gopost no we're we're talking about what
you saying as the one true God we have
to identify that is he a
trinity of course not okay no worries is
does is he a father does he have any
children
no okay cool all right so that's the one
true God the one true God is not a
trinity and he's not a father he has no
Partners right he's not a statute or
anything like that okay cool that's the
one true God all right so now what you
need to do is you need to Pro excuse me
you need to prove to me that Jesus
submitted to this God that you just
described to me that that's who he
believed in and submitted
to don't you believe that he submitted
to the one true
God out of all the other false deities
that were at that time or even at
present time today wouldn't you say he
submitted to the one true God well I I'm
I'm tackling it this way if I were to
say that the that my statute is the one
true God am I a
Muslim did Jesus worship a statute I I
need you to to follow me no no no no I I
I need you to follow it's it's it's a
yes or no if I say that my statute is
the one true God am I a Muslim it's a
simple yes or no as well did Jesus and
there it is man you could probably try
next time try next time no you're not
one you're just dishonest you're
absolutely right you got it you got
it and just like that the men's argument
is
dead because the same script does not
work when are you guys going to learn
this the script doesn't
work y'all need to stop stop doing that
man you know what I'm going to write a
better script for you
guys to help you guys address Jesus
being a Muslim if you want to y'all can
address anything you want but I I'm so
tired of this
script and Muslims like they come off
one after the other one after the other
saying the same exact thing after
watching the first first 100 Muslims
come up here and it not
work matter of
fact it was because of this topic that
one of our new brothers in the faith a
few months ago his name is Husain he was
a Muslim he came up on this topic and it
was because of this topic it opened his
eyes to how Islam has no answers and
makes false
claims then he began to think about
everything then he began to ask about
Christianity and about the real Jesus it
piqued his
interest and glory to God the seed was
planted in him and he became a Christian
the next time I spoke to
him we have witnesses Albi was there
Alby was uh one of the ones that helped
lead him in his confession our brother
Alby helped lead him in his confession
it's because of this
topic when you're honest you leave
Islam when you are honest you leave
Islam uh IM
image it looks like it's image of God go
ahead and put it in the private chat it
looks like I obviously you're probably a
Christian with that with that title
huh I'm just letting I'm letting up the
Muslims only on this stream
man this uh this shake got
[Music]
man all right how you doing Tim welcome
Backes say that again where does Jesus
say he's God where does Jesus say he's
God say he's
God yeah can you say hi first at
least bro I don't say hi to cop bro why
not what where does Jesus claim wait why
don't why don't you say why don't you
say hi to caers don't you live with a
bunch of
them know where I live today man do you
do you live with your mom and
dad my mom and dad are
cath are are they
Muslims are they are they Muslims Muslim
is notl
aie are your parents
Muslim but where did Jesus say he's God
man I'm just I'm just asking man I'm
just look we we could be we could be
cool we could be cool bro you you said
you said that you don't you said that
you don't say hi to caers you said you
don't say hi to caers but you live with
them top of that you're lying you live
with you live with cfers you come from
cfers you come from Kar disbelievers
your parents are disbelievers and you
love them where Jesus claim he's gone
man don't get personal just tell me
where what do you mean don't get
personal what are you talking about I'm
just we're just talking about the truth
right bro where does Jesus just say I'm
God bro I'm just trying to see I'm just
trying to see how consistent you are Tim
that's all bro you're never ever gonna
come with the verse Jesus saying he's
God why not you won't he doesn't he
doesn't say it himself he never says I'm
God do you think that works me like
reverse psychology oh you'll never get
the verse so now I'm going to get the
verse that doesn't work up all right go
get the verse then go get the verse
waiting for well well first I would like
to for you to say hello say what's
up but where does Jesus say he's God man
I'm Gonna Leave man you you you can you
can you can go ahead man because you you
know I don't know I don't know why you
come here man I'm leave I'mma leave once
I leave you're gonna say this is where
Jesus said God so I can't say anything
back well I mean I I I'll bring it up
you know just I'm gonna bring it up to
people who say hi first bring it up then
man and bring it up bro
so are you going to admit that your
mother and mom your dad they're cfers
clearly you're not serious bro I'm dead
serious are they are they Muslim I bro
are you not a CAF I don't understand
like why you taking that off I'm not a c
believe in Allah a cafer is a
disbeliever right a c is a disbeliever
right I am a believer I believe in the
Son of God I believe in the god of
Abraham Isaac and Jacob that's who I
serve you don't believe to you reject
them you and your parents are CA no son
God has no Sons God has no partners and
and according to the according to the
scripture you're a catherer according to
what scripture the scripture that your
God says is good and that you should
judge
by are you talking about uh the inil yes
the inil Tim okay so you're claiming the
four gospels of Mark basically
biographies are what uh Jesus
preached oh snap his own biography and
here we are ladies and gentlemen we just
our segment of what is the inil let's
get it y'all yo see I asked you one
question I
just this is a chran
game thank you so much for coming here
ladies and gentlemen this is our seg of
what is the in jail we have
our I asked you one question
so Tim says so Tim is is is saying that
uh that the angil is not a biography of
Jesus so our question so since he knows
Tim slow down Tim you're gonna be able
to talk
relax relax okay just
relax relax he said he said it in theel
he said it in the theel he said it in
the inel Tim does that answer your
question now do you believe he said it
in the inil I want people to see your
games man good yes everybody your game
is busted logic you start you start
making your game is busted logic your
game is busted I just ask you one
question where does Jesus say your game
is busted logic where does he say the
Trinity where does he say he says it in
the he mentions all of that in the bro
you don't have the you don't have oh I
don't have the how do you know how do
you know have it how do you know bro if
you guys had the inil you would have
been Muslims too
why why would I theil talks about the
Trinity and Jesus being being
God theil talks about the Trinity and
Jesus being God why would I be a Muslim
oh the gospels that you have today speak
about the
Trinity the that's a big
the bring the vers do you doubt that do
you doubt that it's in theel bring the
verses that's a big is it in the I never
claimed it you claimed it no you you
said that we don't have the you claimed
it you said it's in there hey hey take
care T
bye man that's so disappointing when we
don't even get to get into the segment
man I love this segment I love it what's
the inel but for some reason for some
odd reason my friends here can't get
past the first
question just so upset and nervous golly
relax all right
just
relax goodness
gracious good googly
moly let's try another one see how this
goes Muslims please join if you are a
Christian I am not bringing you guys up
today as you see the link says Muslims
only so please adhere to the Stream
hello what's going on uh
honcho hey man look I'm Christian so
should I jump off yes you should jump
off I'll jump off all
right how do I jump off I got I got you
thank you thank you
hey how you doing what's up Mike are you
a
Muslim yes
sir all right all right all right would
you like to talk about
something whatever you want to talk
about why are you a
Muslim why am I Muslim yeah because I
submit to God and God only I mean a lot
of people say they submit to God but
does that make them musl
I I say I to God am I a
Muslim well as long as you worship God
and do God's laws do his part yes it's
possible that you could be muslim okay
so I worship God I do his Commandments I
um am commanded to believe in his son as
my Lord and Savior so I'm I'm doing I'm
a good Muslim right deep down inside you
a
Muslim so I could be a Muslim and
believe that Jesus is the son of God
well on that question I can't be being
honest with you I can't really answer
that question but I believe that Jesus
is Muslim he he follows God's laws he
sends God's
message and I understand that Mary got
pregnant from no reason but God made her
pregnant God can let if it says it be
let it
be if he says be Let It Be
yes
okay that's what I'm talking about yeah
what else we got
right what else we got let it be no be
yeah let it be man let it be no let it
be a no B man let it be a no be
exactly and and a lot of people don't
even really understand that you know yes
they don't a lot of people don't
understand let it be no be
man yeah yeah for real I'm I'm just you
know that's some insight that a lot of
these people man they not um honestly
they not ready for in this generation if
I'm being real right right you know uh
man hashtag y'all let it be no be man
let it let it be no be man hash let ITB
no be real talk man these guys uh man
you bringing some real insight hey I
thank you for bringing up bringing that
wisdom man I'm G let somebody come up
and hopefully we can uh help guide them
man let it be no be no problem no
problem
got yep take care baby yeah all right
all
right let it be no be man let it be no
be